welcome back all our we have celebrated
how powerful music can be in our lives
releasing interviews from musicians
we've never aired before now I want to
share some music from an emerging artist
who's all about using their songs to
advocate for others they've been
featured and billboard and rolling stone
now performing disappear off their
latest album pill box give it up for
Grace Gustin
[Applause]
[Music]
probably don't know
the tensions
you just
know how to hurt me the best
distant
[Music]
I never thought you'd make me cry but
there's nothing behind your eyes
[Music]
I could make it disappear
Ed
[Music]
like
I can make it disappear
if you're Anywhere But Here
[Music]
if I'm doing somebody else
I never thought you'd make me cry but
there's nothing behind your eyes
[Music]
I could make you disappear
Ed
I could make it disappear
[Music]
but here
I could make you disappear
I could make you disappear always end up
with the wrong Obsession Keep On Walking
in the wrong direction
baby this is
no question I can make you disappear
[Music]
cause I wish I
could make you disappear
one more time everybody
pick up their new album pill box
wherever you get your music please
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]